everyone's weird now
the internet either allows us to be
weirder or makes us weirder i'm not sure
what's the right way to put it maybe a
mix of both
you're probably right that it allows us
to be weirder because
well this is the other okay so this
connects our previous conversation
is does america allow us to be weirder
or does it
uh make us weirder like say we're weird
and somewhat neurotic to begin with
but the only messages we get are dwight
d eisenhower and
i love lucy and network tv like that's
going to keep us within certain bounds
yeah in good and bad ways that's
obviously totally gone
and the internet you can connect to not
just q and on but all sorts of things
many of them just fantastic
right yeah uh but in good and bad ways
it makes us weirder
so that maybe is troubling right like if
someone's worried about that i would at
least say they should
give it deep serious thought and then it
has a whole lot of
ebbs and flows micro realizations of the
weirdness
that don't actually matter so like chess
players today they play a lot more weird
openings than they did 20 years ago
like it reflects the same thing because
you can research any weird opening on
the internet but like does that matter
probably not so a lot of the things we
see are just like the weird chess
openings
and to figure out which are like the
weird chess openings and which are
fundamental
to the new and growing weirdness like
that's what a hedge fund investor type
should be trying to do
i just think no one knows yet it's like
this itself this fun weird guessing game
which we're partly engaging in right now
exactly
you